terre ce que pourtant fait la chine est
ce que peuvent faire les états unis donc
sans lieu en effet nous sommes démunis
on change tout à fait de sujets
maintenant si vous le voulez bien
pour parler de ce témoignage d'adèle
enel cette actrice qui s'est longuement
confié à nos confrères de mediapart pour
dénoncer un harcèlement sexuel dont elle
affirme hôtel était l'objet lorsqu'elle
était très jeune actrice elle avait
moins de moins de 15 ans à l'époque de
la part du réalisateur christophe ruggia
alors cette affaire a fait énormément de
bruit christophe ruggia a été révoqué de
la société des réalisateurs de films
dont il avait été président alors même
qu'il réfute catégoriquement tous les
faits qui lui sont reprochés et on a
appris tout à l'heure que le parquet de
paris a ouvert une enquête préliminaire
dans cette affaire sachant que adèle
haenel
elle ne souhaitait pas aller en justice
car elle expliqué que de toute façon la
justice n'était pas vraiment à l'écouté
des victimes de ce type d'acte écoutez
la réaction à cette position de nicole
belloubet la garde des sceaux et je
conseillerais adèle hélène enel d'aller
en justice si elle n'y va pas en justice
ça veut dire que cet homme christophe
rhodia et condamner publiquement sans
avoir été jugé qu'il est condamné d'une
certaine hier par un tribunal médiatique
est ce que ça ne vous interroge pas s'il
est garde des sceaux et si dans ces
cas-là ciel ne porte pas plainte à ce
que le parquet peut se saisir
c'est difficile qu'ils se saisissent la
sur les faits tels que je les ai lus
mais vraiment je pense qu'il y a
presqu'une nécessite de poser cette
question à la justice pour que les
choses soient très clairement et
objectivement elle en sortira renforcée
et la situation de la personne qui est
mise en cause également alors on la
prend au passage le côté un petit peu
approximatif de la position de la garde
des sceaux qui disait que c'était
difficile pour le parquet de paris de se
saisir ce qui n'a pas empêcher celui ci
de faire quelques heures après la
question qu'on se posait c'est à la
justice de décider nicolas corato c'est
quand même que ce qu'il ya une espèce de
justice parallèle parce qu'aujourd'hui
bas ce réalisateur de films ville est
considérée médiatiquement au
publiquement comme coupable malgré ses
dénégations
oui c'est un débat qu'on a depuis depuis
mythe
depuis ce qu'il ya eu d'autres d'autres
cas où effectivement on a opposé
finalement la cause politique militante
qui a permis cette libération de la
parole et puis les faits de cette
libération de la parole sur des
situations individuelles sur la
présomption d'innocence et c'est moi
j'entends quand même je j'encourage vos
téléspectateurs à aller regarder
l'interview d' adèle haenel sur
mediapart parce que justement elle
traite ce sujet là et elle explique que
le sujet est tellement sensible
tellement majeur tellement essentiel
pour l'avenir de notre démocratie et des
femmes en france que la justice a montré
ses limites et qu' effectivement la
justice n'est plus le lieu idoine pour
aller traiter ce sujet quand elle vous
dit et on doit l'entendre et la garde
des sceaux devrait l'entendre également
que effectivement un viol sur dix est
condamné il ya sur 10 affaire de viol
vous il ya une condamnation qui a des
femmes victimes qui ont un chemin mais
de decroix pour aller apporter la preuve
de leur agression que le nombre
d'agressions sexuelles dans une certaine
génération depuis des années 70 et
démence dire qu'on a des chiffres qui
tournent tous deux une femme a deux
femmes sur cinq qui aurait été agressée
sexuellement notamment par des proches
pendant son enfance son adolescence ou
ou le début de l'âge adulte
tous ces sujets là font que
effectivement la réponse de la justice
et quand un délai neil dit la justice et
pas du tout en phase avec ce combat là
en phase avec ces idées là moi je prends
un exemple parce qu'il faut un moment
objectiver les choses il y à un
instrument qui s'appelle l' ordonnance
de protection qui permet à un juge de
mettre une femme à l'abri des violences
conjugales n'est pas complètement dans
le cas d' adèle haenel mais on est gay
exactement dans le même débat
ça fait 4 garde des sceaux successifs
qui n'arrête pas de dire aux magistrats
saisissez vous de ces ordonnances de
protection prononcé des ordonnances de
protection
on est aujourd'hui à 1 % dans deux ans
de production prononcée en cas de
violence conjugale
on voit bien effectivement que la
machine judiciaire elle n'est pas prête
à affronter ce débat de société est le
traité et il y a dans la parole d'adp et
les nail au delà de la présomption
d'innocence à laquelle a droit à la
personne qu'elle met en cause il y a
dans son combat politique quelque chose
qui interroge les fondamentaux de notre
état effectivement moi je pense que la
justice en france n'est plus à la
hauteur
certain nombre de sujets essentiels pour
notre démocratie et qu'on s'en
désintéressent qu'on ne veut pas la
réforme et qu'on ne veut pas réformer la
magistrature et cas et on arrive à ce
sujet là où effectivement moi je
regrette que la présomption d'innocence
soit mise en cause et je regrette que
cette personne soit jugée médiatiquement
avant de l'être judiciairement mais
j'entends aussi la parole d'adp hélène
elle qui dit que la justice n'est plus à
même de traiter son cas enfin d'eysines
à vous partager ce constat sur la
justice française sur ces sujets moi je
crois que ce qui est intéressant dans le
témoignage d'anne enel est finalement
dans le mouvement plus global demi-tour
en général c'est que l'arsenal
législatif est en réalité déjà très
complet sur ces questions on distingue
les agressions sexuelles le harcèlement
mais c'est la preuve de ce type
d'agissements qui est très difficile à
apporter
et tout ce qui concerne la le combler
les moments à deux est très difficile à
jury 10,6 et donc je ne crois pas que
nous manquons moyens que nous manquons
de formation où l'on rencontre une
législation dans ce domaine
néanmoins je crois que ce que pointe adl
enel c'est que cet arsenal législatif
n'est pas mise à profit par rapport à un
manque de culture aussi des personnes
qui sont les premières sur les lieux
c'est à dire les forces de police par
exemple un manque de culture de
protection de la femme est donc en
quelque sorte pointé l'idée qu'un
changement de mentalité doit précéder le
changement de législation n'est pas
complètement in intelligent il ya
quelque chose qui fait souffrir la
juriste que je suis néanmoins c'est les
droits de la défense et je pense que
sollicité le tribunal médiatique c'est
intéressant pour faire bouger les
consciences
néanmoins je crois que le parquet a bien
agi en prenant le relais en démontrant
que il faudrait désormais que les choses
s'apaisent notamment pour la personne
qui est accusé
si elle est accusée à tort mais le
changement de mentalité ça peut être une
bonne idée pour en tout cas arriver à
mobiliser ce que nous avons déjà 169 % à
considérer que l'affairé elle ne devait
pas se limiter à une sorte de procès
médiatique c'est à dire qu'il était
nécessaire que la justice se saisisse de
ce sujet puis voici deux commentaires
que je vous livre
spitz anne qui nous dit la libération de
la parole c'est très bien mais cela
n'empêche pas qu'une parole puisse être
mensongère
et puis babineau avec la puissance des
médias et des réseaux sociaux il n'y a
plus de présomption d'innocence coupable
ou innocent le mal est déjà fait
bertrand du marais votre point de vue
moi je trouve que effectivement ce qui
concerne le débat médiatique il faut une
grande grande prudence une grande
retenue vis-à-vis des autres guillemets
accusé cantonner la présomption
d'innocence et aussi vis-à-vis des
victimes parce que j'allais dire pour
une victime qui est qui en particulier
quand il s'agit de pédocriminalité c'est
sa vie comment dire ça
sa vie affective qui a été atteinte et
en général d'ailleurs qui a été atteinte
pour toute sa vie et ça n'est pas très
facile
j'allais dire de dalles et je crois que
de ce point de vue là adèle haenel a eu
beaucoup de courage mais mais parce que
ça doit être extrêmement remuant pour
elle et donc il ya beaucoup aussi de
victimes qui n'osent pas remuer en
quelque sorte ces questions donc bon moi
je serais assez prudent j'ai crû
comprendre qu au contraire notamment du
point de vue des services de police et
d'un certain nombre de magistrats il y
avait une écoute de plus en plus
satisfaisante notamment pour la question
des femmes battues qui est pas tout à
fait la question de la pédocriminalité
maintenant j'aimerais introduire un
exemple qui n'est pas très reluisant qui
est celui de l'église l'église
catholique connaît des problèmes de
pédocriminalité après déjà les dires des
égarements doctrinaux d un certain
nombre de de claire qui ont été ou qui
sont en voie d'être d'être jugé est elle
à jaillir à côté de la de la procédure
juridique judiciaire
elle a créé cette commission qui un peu
à dire un peu ce que les sud africains
avaient fait après l'apartheid vérité et
réconciliation c'est à dire d'abord que
les victimes puissent se présenter
qu'on fasse un travail de vérité aussi
qui n'est pas nécessairement un travail
judiciaire
et ça je pense que c'est peut-être un
élément qui manque dans la problématique
j'allais dire dans d'autres secteurs
alors on verra ce que ça donnera
peut-être que ce sera un échec on en
sait rien c'est à paris en instance qui
et qui est présidée par l'ancien patron
vice-président du conseil d'état
est ce que vous considérez qui sont
maintenant que les médias se comportent
comme à l'aller milhas n'existe pas mais
globalement comme il convient dans ce
type d'affaires c'est un sujet
extrêmement complexe puisqu'on est dans
une évolution extra juridique des
sociétés complètement la question du
droit ça vient d'être révoqué ne couvre
pas la dimension profondément
traumatisante la meurtrissure avis que
représente ce genre d'acte pour la
personne qui les suit et pourtant elle
doit se déclarer un jour et parfois dix
ou quinze ans après ceux qui échappent
encore une fois à une construction de
type juridique puisque il ya des
problèmes de prescription et à des
problèmes de reconstitution des faits il
ya des problèmes c'est bien ce que je
disais au départ extra juridique
il faut donc on arrive à un stade qu'on
appelait autrefois morale à régler ça
alors les médias sont l'espèce de vase
d'expansion de ce mouvement là et qui a
trait à des valeurs fondamentales qui
sont l'égalité la dignité de la femme et
de l'enfant encore plus choquant donc
dans le cas de lna il s'agit d'un acte
de pédophilie
c'est extrêmement grave ça s'est passé
entre 12 et 15 c'est ça c'est ça c'est
extrêmement grave
donc si c'est avéré mais comment la
justice va-t-elle reconstituer tout cela
le seul fait de d'entendre la personne
accusée d'un produit juridique abouti à
une sorte de mise en accusation de toute
façon c'est pas les médias qui en sont
des responsables alors pour répondre à
votre question un chant guillaume
moi je crois que les médias doivent
gérer ça avec un sens moral plus élevé
que ce n'est le cas à l'heure actuelle
c'est à dire qu'il s'agit pas de faire
un coup médiatique
il s'agit de encore une fois d'une mer
très sûr très profonde de la personne
humaine et il faut exercer cette
responsabilité avec un nouveau sens des
responsabilités vers 6 et les médias qui
doivent recueillir ce que la justice ne
peut pas enregistrer ou si la victime
c'est que va se confier plus facilement
un média que un juge est bien dans ce
cas là il faut changer les règles de
responsabilité des médias aussi c'est
assez courageuse que fait adèle haenel
on sait pas ce que la justice dira mais
elle préfère la bataille culturelle à la
bataille judiciaire et la bataille
culturelle elle a des mots assez forts
elle parle d'une culture du viol qui est
qui sous tend notre société patriarcale
depuis des années c'est un débat mais
c'est intéressant qu elles le portent et
c'est un débat que vous ne pouvez pas
porter dans le débat judiciaire
ce débat là il a besoin des caisses de
résonance des médias pour prospérer
donc c'est le pari qu'elle fait c'est un
pari respectable avec certaines
contraintes et aussi les conséquences
on va parler d'une autre affaire
judiciaire mais là cette fois ci il ya
eu la condamnation elle a même eu deux
c'est celle de patrick balkany